welcome to this video playing for phony
and I'm fading it what is this for flag
may become bacha or something hong kong
SAR china has screwed this up I screwed
this up before it's a China okay um what
okay maybe a Queens gambit they haven't
haven't played this for ages let's see
maybe a Tartar cover Alaska variation is
really a bit down to play on video okay
this is one of the absolute main lines
ah how does this black play here not
sure we see six or can you go it's got
the bishop on e2 okay I'm playing this
in this in this conservative fashion at
some another bet bet setup night is
coming to e6 and the bishop on f6 they
both put some pressure on on white
center so that if or is not so so easily
played still I wonder guy might still
play for 90 64
takes Knight takes yeah maybe I can take
it on deform looks a bit shaky but maybe
I can do that yeah this is a fairly
typical position father for the chatter
kuva while enjoys very healthy too
healthy structure blacks has the two
bishops but on b7 okay this Bishop is
not especially brilliant black would
like to play c5 under the right
circumstances but at the moment there's
probably too much pressure on the center
you cannot easily play it c5 I mean I'm
not snot my move but in general he will
probably take it and then d fibers under
too much pressure huh but I'm close to a
position where if see 5 or might be
viable I can still play on some
improvement moves first Oh is playing
that anyway interesting I thought takes
Knight takes bishop d4 would be possible
hmm not sure yeah I don't need to take
really it's not a false move but i don't
i don't really see it at the moment why
I shouldn't take on deform it's greedy
but it's a central pawn I'm willing to
do some slight stance to win a central
pawn okay and this was the idea i have
c5 though
preen preen my bishop this is very
important I'm not quite sure if this is
enough compensation what is exactly is
he doing ok now I cannot take with the
night I must take with the porn no
that's not great ok but still it's a
it's a pond deform yeah it might get
lost but I don't really I don't have a
bad piece really wish upon v7s in good
shape ok interesting just Queen f6 maybe
this is not all 95 it may be here
lending some third the support to e6
covering deform may be preparing night f
form
and just looks good for life or black I
mean maybe Kenny's for taking all these
six try to win it back I don't know I
can play route yet supportive or don't
really see him a big problem here okay
throw the exchanges yeah I guess so
doesn't make much sense to take what the
pawn now maybe night h5 may I got 325 is
a good reply I think okay he's attacking
the pawn group the editors taking on a
seven okay and e5 maybe not sure check
out if I go here now okay okay it's just
taking our taking some control here how
do i do I win this now
well at the moment I'm a slight problem
is my bishop the bishop is not great as
f3 really a killed Sam its scope and
while nights are notoriously tricky so I
must be a must be a bit I must be
cautious let's see why this was maybe
bad if he takes it and a text no I
thought if he takes it and maybe just
just a check c5 but I didn't really see
a great grandmother okay I'm taking the
sea fall I wanted to go Quinn see to it
he maybe has the Queen e6 check oh wait
i have d 3 check actually is the sims d3
hmm not sure no it's not it's not really
needing to to anything substantial time
morning how about Queenie to is not
really helping much that's not so easy
it's not so easy to win I mean maybe I'm
just playing it in a very stupid fashion
but he's got some activity you have the
bishop is bad on b7 anyway so yeah I'd
like to take it still the night oops
this I didn't see
now with this I don't mind this looks
like a decent control check check check
check-check yard finally check finally
getting the Queen's off check check
check white for things from time oh yeah
there was always a bit of a it was
somewhat too much shaky maybe I was just
playing a bad lame possibly around here
black it's um it's a very very good very
good shape but I probably allowed too
much activity him yeah here yeah I
thought you should take actually like
this and then but i can probably maybe i
can push the sea por now i mean this
this looks like some sort of repetition
but if you go see I maybe I can push
simply
yeah there should be very good for black
prob'ly this is enough probably that's
enough with the strong pawn ok went here
oops id3 was hanging I didn't I didn't I
didn't see a real real follow up yeah i
saw this i saw this but i didn't really
solve the about just did to wear this is
this is true yeah i can just play the to
him now that's very easy actually I can
so what I did is basically just keep the
position as it was keep the pawn g6 is
winning the piece I'm not not to alert
at the moment technically check check
check this keeps check keeps the winning
hand but i miss change a good
continuation the others this is a window
with the porn supported by the rook and
the space advantage yeah tough game at
the end I think if you return to hear
its it's probably not really a good
sacrifice what what could still play
looking for maybe now ok it's a
complicated position right on the out of
the opening but I don't think it was a
sound Fonseca really alright thanks for
watching